اشارات لجنه يبيع امريكيه
5800 صفحه من ملفات الضرائب الخاصه
بالرئيس الامريكيه السابق دونالد ترامب
وهي تغطي سنتين قبل توليها الرئاسه واربعه
اعوام من وجوده في البيت الابيض انها بدون
شكل سابقه في الحياه السياسيه الامريكيه
ومن الواضح ان الديمقراطيين تعمدوا النشر
بانتخابات لعام 2016 ان يلحقوا به الضرار
السياسي بقدر المستطاع لن يصرف المواطن
الامريكي الساعات الطويله للتحقيق في
مضمون الوثائق بل سيكتفي الامريكي بما
توضيحه له وسائل الاعلام المؤيده لترامب
او المعارضه له خلاصه التصريحات الضريبيه
تشير الى ان ترامب دفع صفر ضرائب في العام
2020 بسبب خسائر تجاريه ودفع 750$ في
العامين 2016 و2017
وفي السنوات الاخرى دفع اما بين
133,000 دولار وما يقارب المليون من
الواضح ان الديمقراطيين استهدف ترامب بهذا
النشر قبل ان يسيطر الجمهوريون على مجلس
النواب في الاسبوع المقبل
دونالد ترامب ترى فقط مع التحقيقات في
اقتحام مبنى الكونجرس في السادس من يناير
العام 2021
ويعتبر المعارضون ترامب انه لن يتمكن من
النهوض سياسيا بعد الان
وغالبيتهما وهذا ما همس لاعضاء الحزب
الجمهوري بان ترامب اصبح من الماضي
تحديات حقيقيه
على الحزب الجمهوريه ان يقرر ما يفعله ان
يبقى مع ترامب او يتابعونه
وهذه هي المشكله الاكبر